thousand ago and rest but it's pure hi
and welcome to the cat lady it's been a
game that uh I've been neglecting to
play for a long time and mainly because
I didn't really like the art style of it
I know that sounds really hipster and
pretentious but I'm not saying it's bad
I just kind of turned me off a little
bit but I keep hearing so many amazing
things about this game and I think it'll
be a great a great adventure a great
story as I hope your boss will join me
on it let's the wet guess now I have
this new setup while I'm in miss Susan
Ashwin I'll talk to you later
I live alone in this old two-bedroom
flat I rarely go outside it actually
looks pretty beautiful I take back what
I said about the art style honestly
some would say it's a lonely life and I
guess that's true but I don't like
people's company well not lately anyway
that's okay Susan oh [ __ ] Susan you're
beautiful I only trust my cats these
days and I will miss them dearly they
will understand the Catholic they always
have teacup stays with me till the end
teacup that's one of the which is me as
if he knew tell her not to do a teacup
you have to tell her you gotta stop her
mine
pick up walkies earlier tonight I
swallowed a whole bunch of pills they're
legal of course prescribed by my doctor
for my sleeping freedoms but I've taken
34
I could find in the cupboard same girl
how the room around me spins in a blurry
tango as my heart slows down so either
we go back in time and see why she kill
herself or second now she doesn't die I
will be dead I feel calm I'm ready for
it
I've only got one thing to say now I
really take back what I said about their
art style it's actually really cool what
is a we only got one thing huh
goodbye come on Zeus and don't be like
that
you got teacup isn't he something I
think teacup is something it was
beautiful
I don't even like cats that much but
peek Cup was [ __ ] gorgeous and you
know it you know I see you I see you
knowing it Chapter five oh one is that
the slender jump-scare sound yes house
in the woods
alright [ __ ] Slenderman is gonna be
in this game I know it is in every game
Harvester game for sense I feel awful
for judging this game by the art style I
don't know some screenshot I saw that
which is kind of awkward I don't know
this looks beautiful seems pretty damn
interesting so far as well so do I move
somehow press ok I did that but I don't
mind
this is gladiator
I think so ah where are we going we're
going towards the light but what about
teacup Susan
what about pika how could you Susan just
abandoned teacup like that I don't even
know I don't want to look at you
technically you're not looking at me
either it's locked
well [ __ ] I feel strangely drawn to this
place I must find a way to unlock this
padlock and get inside well it's still
wet
oh this is a lot [ __ ] creepier hey
car idling oh [ __ ] this is game up jump
scares in it it's better not I jump
skate I love cars I had the one hello
yes just like a 40 Cup
no pedestrian access haha thug life
go what anyway what's up what's up hey
that's how you doing okay cool what the
[ __ ] why would you do that they are me I
got damnit Mikula face sorry and read
that press open interactions menu cycle
through available options or sensor to
confirm ok let's examine it paramedic
ambulance this ambulance blocking access
to the tunnel exit maybe there is no
exit at all let's open the door let's
see what's inside
come on citizen you can do it just use
your boots for I see those ABS of yours
they are huge
no well [ __ ] I guess we gotta go back
shut up down
I'm playing here except a dog wanna be
in a cat lady game that doesn't make any
sense what's making that noise
uh-oh I don't like this bro-chachos slow
hi is that answer me Jesus are you oh my
god what the [ __ ] is that me
and I look hot I mean it's me my cold
dead body right in front of my eyes
what's it doing here I don't like this
game [ __ ] creepy I look so calm - aah
open eyes I don't wanna do that giving
me the goose abouthe just about one
thing I lie to by myself
even now they still shine a little why
would you oh why oh it's a Cato and in
sight I'll better take it with me
alright press down to open inventory is
like 9 okay so maybe this goes to the
ambulance
sorry use Kent okay well sorry how do I
close this okay up All Right see you
later citizen it was nice knowing you
alright I skipped this is really awesome
so far this game I really didn't expect
this at all but yeah let's go to that
high bus how ya doin
I thought [ __ ] you boss god damn I know
it I couldn't trust you the first time I
saw you I was being polite and [ __ ]
ironic whoa
ah damn how can I die this is like die
dead section I died while being dead you
know I'm saying you do ha ha
you must be as high as I am what I'm not
high hi I'm life that's what I say hi
car I can trust you right
good good car good car I'll give you
okay I'll send you a postcard
it's that I'll look I'll do that why
didn't the heavens ark is going on here
this is this is hey it's you Jesus
hey come on man don't call
what is he doing are you doing
all right well we're going in here for
now yeah use the key I thought we've
been through this season okay down
select use okay I can't see it it's my
[ __ ] that are you hide so then so
then don't don't done mess with me
please thank God now advice oh [ __ ]
discrete hello thanks I love thanks pull
it
I'm not strong enough to pull them with
my bare hands look through there's
definitely something there I can't tell
for sure but it looks like a switch the
sign only says emergency power switch
danger yellow am i right
switch on how strange there seems to be
a single switch or button on this
machine how do you turn it on okay let's
ask Jesus what he has to say about this
I'm sure he has quite a quite a few
things to say hi jaysus why not it was
so beautiful I love them
Maya
god damnit Don hey hey we're playing I
don't [ __ ] know what it's called in
English catch is that it maybe I'll
become a deer eventually that'll be
pretty sweet I was gonna be a deer just
roll around in the dirt all day and like
fight with my horns and [ __ ] is it
raining
oh it's burning yep Susan why do you
keep god I kill yourself man girl
okay so then seriously though why don't
want to sup with us my dead body hanging
from a tree I should be scared but I
just feel empty wait what's that shiny
thing on her neck is that a key god damn
it Susan why you gotta hide keys in [ __ ]
my body's too high I can't reach oh we
can untie this rope it would take me
hours hours Susan I thought
females are really good at like untying
things because they're I don't know I
don't okay the door seems to be bolted
on the other side
well this [ __ ] is just full of dead ends
isn't it I mean you're dead siz and it's
not like in a couple hours it's gonna
cause you any trouble
I can't remember this place lost Susan
you're dead don't complain now okay what
the [ __ ] is stuck is crooked how's it
going hey I thought we were friends
croaker and you just spit in my face
Cammie
funky music man oh hey it's you guys
what's up look it is so [ __ ] creepy
what a gruesome display at least it's
not my head stuck on tomorrow
good point Susan I
like a everything in this game is
[ __ ] locked goddammit
alright let's keep going I am [ __ ]
locked crow cut why are you doin hidin
manager
I'm loving this game though farts also
go good but what he want he wants to
tell me something
maybe hey how's it go no why did I turn
around oh okay let's try and go back now
and maybe that'll be something different
that's what I'm guessing for is this
different I don't even remember Fred
Jania spear cyclicamp two points for
kids did you stay before me haha don't
lie brush don't lie it's not cool when
you lie we both know I'm more genius I
mean I'm dunia spits okay you can be
second genius is that okay is that a
deal good good
you know what don't talk back to me
you're beautiful but you're not that
beautiful I'm kidding you're gorgeous
okay what am I even doing here
nope we're not going that again
hi it's you again how you doing you're
just ignoring me now aren't you you
little [ __ ] but I am going through your
body here that is pretty sweet I think I
discovered it a little bug a scart
hiding behind their bug that's ok with
me not complaining all right let's just
follow the crow now this new setup it's
not perfect I know it's not perfect but
why the [ __ ] did the crow go um I'm
still working on it
oh yes I just keep following again um
and hopefully it'll be good eventually I
know it's not that good right now but um
I like it I always wanted to have a
green screen I think it it's bad no your
brother really liked to sink that's
behind me in LA but what does [ __ ] know
not why would you why would you stab a
deer how could you how could you
god dammit I cut off his face what the
[ __ ] huh well who's done this is there
anyone else here I think it was the crow
no you don't think so what do you
thinking what do you know about stabbing
deers huh hey we're here that's a
shortcut what's up hi Susan how you
doing let me just uh
ah Susan let me just use the knife oh I
thought she was gonna stab whoa
ah look closer don't jump-scare me don't
jump-scare me examine I look like I'm
just sleeping empty take the key all
right I'll see you later Susan you keep
snoozing ha ha ha ha Oh Mae I am the
funniest man alive except for Susan and
teacup
they are pretty damn funny alright let's
go inside the pigs too and then I'll and
I'll have to do for today because I'm
still just setting up I it took me a lot
of time to UM get where I get this going
and stuff like that I haven't not been
slacking out for anything whoa I do not
alike at the DS hello oh [ __ ]
ok welcome to my house Susan Ashworth
oh [ __ ] was she one have been waiting
for you my dear my dear I knew it I know
I got my dear tena
one fine day Alexis whoo
who are you I have so many days it's
hard to pick one this is creeping me out
man
I'm curious who do you think I am I
think you are Oprah why does that option
not stay here an old lady who lives in
the lady who lives in the woods is that
funny oh is that funny am I really Susan
oh that's nice okay you're correcting me
out here girl perhaps you're too
stubborn to see me yeah okay okay you're
not Oprah I got that now oh that time
for you now you disappoint I'm sorry
wasted your time waiting I'm not worth
waiting for
I'm just nobody writes isn't thought you
have Kika seriously why are you so that
for me you're just a strange old woman
sitting on a porch of her house those
flowers you're holding what are they for
anyway now for you Susan I'm going to
put some on your coffee after everyone's
gone I wouldn't bother my Suze I hate
Susan stop babe okay what happened
things happen next depends on you Susan
come on I don't want to do anything
inside my house there are dark hallways
that lead to places you don't want to
see but there is also something that
will make you want to return to where
you came from harsh every single little
breath you take every breath you make
you an offer
Susan it's a chance only a fool would
refuse okay
and offer what can you offer be let's
come inside no thanks um it's getting
cold the deer all right brother I'm
gonna end its episode here
hope you enjoyed leave a like for you
serious it really has me out a lot to
get them started I think this would be a
really really epic epic one